hello how is your linear algebra are you
good at multiplying matrices or at
computing eigenvalues or at inverting a
matrix yes
no
well you're saved because this paper
solves nine linear algebra problems with
transformers wait miss coffee bean why
do we need transformers to do this it's
not like we wouldn't have exact programs
computing these things
well thanks reviewer 2 for ruining the
research mood by asking practical
questions here and doubting the
usefulness of a transformer
solving linear algebra problems and to
you our viewer welcome to this ai coffee
break where we will explain how a
transformer can do linear algebra and
also why this is cool and the useful
thing to do in the first place but do
you know what else is useful miss coffee
being that for the sponsor for today's
video thanks to weights and biases for
supporting us for this video now we can
fill up our coffee machine and the
chocolate box
and do not tell us you were living under
a pile of coffee beans and did not hear
about weights and biases yet weights and
biases is a ml ops platform helping you
to build better machine learning models
faster it helps you track your
experiments with beautiful plots did it
ever happen to you that you overwrote
training settings for a special model
and you couldn't reproduce it anymore
well with weights and biases this will
never happen again because all the
configs are saved and you can use sweeps
to optimize hyper parameters while
sitting back and drinking your coffee
but surely this luxury is super hard to
integrate wait what it isn't you can
integrate weights and biases with just a
few lines of code okay then how much
money do i have to spend for this luxury
miss coffee bean
nothing because it's free for personal
use and for academic teams alright
of course if you're one of the big
players you have to take out some money
of your thick wallet but if you're a
student like me who wants to stay
organized even in the advent of the
paper deadline while all your coffee
beans are going crazy and everything's a
mess and irreproducible from that
chaotic excellent spreadsheet you use
for tracking experiments then you should
give way to biases a try now let's get
back to our linear algebra in this paper
the authors say we consider problems of
linear algebra but we who now we
francois and charton right
just kidding we are laughing about the
scientific way of writing oui even when
the paper was written by a single author
there are even better things to laugh
about when it comes to scientific
publishing like for example the case of
the physicist who used his cat as a
co-author to conform to publication
standards read that story on wikipedia
it's linked in the description below
so they the authors use a transformer to
perform nine numerical calculations from
linear algebra matrix transposition
matrix addition matrix vector
multiplications eigenvalues and
eigenvectors singular values and svd and
finally matrix inversion but why would
anyone ever want to do that it's not
like we do not have algorithms for these
problems already why do matrix inversion
with transformers well we have at least
one reason we could present to you i
think miss coffee bean is not the only
one who is curious to know what are the
limits of what transformers can do can
transformers be applied on text oh yes
they can can they process images yes
they can do they work on speech of
course they do can they do math
well it depends on what kind of math we
had a video where we explained the
transformers that do symbolic
integration transformers also have been
shown to prove theorems do formal logic
solve sat problems symbolic regression
dynamical systems and so on see the
paper for references so for symbolic
mathematics transformers seem to work
well but how are they with numbers
luckily this is what the authors are
basically asking too there have been
investigations on sequence to sequence
models for arithmetic tasks showing how
transformers do not work that well on
this check out the related work if
you're interested to know about this
part but the linear algebra problems as
chosen by the authors
answer a broader spectrum of questions
from little easy tasks to complex ones
can transformers do basic operations on
individual coefficients of matrices like
it is the case with matrix transposition
and addition can they also do
compositions of several arithmetic
operations like it is the case with
matrix multiplication and then can they
even do complex non-linear
transformations with cubic complexity
like the matrix decompositions and
matrix inversion and then
what about generalization
does a transformer trained on one type
of matrices generalized to another type
of matrices and also what about view
shot learning can trained transformers
be further tuned to solve even larger
problems by only a few examples a few
this is view shot learning after all so
you see the test here is big ranging
from simple operations to more
complicated arithmetic to advanced
algorithms i learned about in university
in my linear algebra classes but miss
coffee bean to date has not heard of
them yet so she calls numpy linux all
the time in her blissful programmer
ignorance but i see you are not
convinced or motivated yet to use the
transformer overkill to solve these
problems are you reviewer 2 here then
let's look beyond the paper into even
more arguments made by the authors
during their rebuttal one argument is
that it is important to test the limits
of transformers if we want to apply
these to science just
think about deepmind's alpha fold in
biology or transformers as a replacement
for mathematica so the question is
whether certain computational building
blocks can be performed inside a
transformer because if yes then one step
is clear when chasing the question of
applicability of transformers in science
they can do linear algebra one more
argument that the authors make which
miss coffee bean seems to like the most
is that transformers are usually used as
end-to-end solutions let's suppose that
for the solution we must compute some
arithmetic operation or some linear
algebra it would be impractical when
time and resources are critical to step
out of the transformer to perform these
operations so having a network or a sub
network implementing these operations in
neurons is simply comfortable and
practical two more arguments focus on
providing general insight on
transformers that are small
we are not talking about gbt3 size
models here but about shallow simple
models that one scientist can train on
his gpu at home also the encodings
representations and insight can be used
for purposes other than linear algebra
but okay miss coffee been enough with
the motivation we got it this is
research it has all the positive
practical outcomes we just mentioned
it's fine to do something only because
we can and because we can learn
something from doing it it is research
it does not have to land directly into
the app store to make money out of it in
any case now that we are over motivated
with transformers solving linear algebra
problems and we think that is cool let's
dive into explaining how this is done
well to work on matrices with
transformers one needs two things
matrices and transformers
of course the challenge here is to
represent the matrices so the input into
a format that a transformer can process
the other challenge is to understand
transformers for this maybe you want to
check out one of our previous videos
we remember that transformers work with
sets and if the sets elements have an
order we speak of sequential data the
transformer encodes the order of the
data in positional embeddings and
matrices have a structure an order so we
need to somehow transform these
two-dimensional tables into sequences
nothing easier than this one can do it
by taking the numbers and writing them
one after the other their order would be
then captured in positional embeddings
the authors
also prepend a coding of the size of the
matrix this gives the transformer
further information about the matrix
dimensionality so the transformer can
leverage this
but
what have we done with coffee bean by
just writing the numbers one after the
other we actually created a vocabulary
for the transformer of infinite size
because there are infinitely many real
numbers the last we checked so encoding
each matrix coefficient with just the
number it represents is a poor decision
because the network would need to learn
representations for each possible number
in the infinitely sized vocabulary
with an infinite vocabulary size it will
surely happen that numbers occurring
during testing will not have occurred
during training then is there a way to
encode the numbers better and maybe have
them represent some prior knowledge
about numbers in general
yes there are at least four as presented
by the authors we are talking about p10
p1000b thousand
and
this coffee bean stop it with the
cryptic codes we're not talking about
the terminator so what is meant is
pretty clear from this table that one
can decompose a floating point number
according to these rules and use a set
of integer numbers still infinite but
they're infinity smaller than the
infinity of the real numbers and other
symbols this means that the knowledge
about numbers is explicated for example
in the p10 and p1000 representations we
explicitly have the information of
whether the number is positive or
negative and this is explicitly stated
in a separate token so yes each number
is tokenized into five tokens in the p10
representation so the sequence length is
blown up by five times but this also
means that the sign of the number is a
special token in the vocabulary so the
plus token is shared among all positive
numbers in the vocabulary if we get a
new yet unseen number during testing
with the p10 representation the
transformer will have an easier time the
sign token is known these integer tokens
are also known so there is a trade-off
between how much a number is decomposed
into a known vocabulary making things
easier and the sequence length making
things also harder when training
transformers cool so now that we know
how the authors encode their matrices
into sequences they just need to create
training data how is there a matrix
database or benchmark lying around
somewhere no need because one can
generate random matrices oneself for the
input to generate the output one just
has to call numpy linux and get the
solution so say welcome to matrix
solution pairs and gather your
transformer and let them do their thing
as a note the paper does work with
relatively small matrices like five
times five six times four two times
thirteen of course a next research
question is postponed for the future
about bigger matrices there's longer
sequences for the transformer and so on
in any case training processes later the
authors
come in to check onto their transformers
and how well they did on each task and
well surprise 90 plus percent accuracy
across the board at least with certain
tolerance levels neural networks are
probabilistic models so one cannot
expect exact results in each matrix
coefficient yes there are some
differences between encodings where
p1000 generally performs best but the
short lesson here is transformers do
work on these nine problems feel free to
gaze at the numbers in the paper link
below because the real question about
neural networks is all right but how
does this generalize this is ai
researcher talk for asking whether the
model is really understanding the task
but miss coffee bean why are you using
the word understanding that's of limits
let's reformulate so the question is
whether the transformer has found the
general algorithm behind let's say
matrix transposition so it can
generalize to types of matrices it has
not seen during training that would be
generalization and this is what the
authors investigate in two ways
the out-of-distribution generalization
experiment in a nutshell the authors
train their models with random n by n
matrices that have the property that the
coefficients are independent and
identically distributed sampled from a
uniform distribution matrices fulfilling
this property are known as wigner
matrices okay so we have the wigner
matrices how does a transformer trained
on wigner matrices perform on other
types of matrices also present in
science well if the test set is composed
of matrices with coefficients that just
have a different standard deviation than
the train set the model only generalizes
if the variance of the coefficients in
the test set is lower than the training
set variance if one increases the
variance the probability to meet a
number outside the training range
increases two and the model kind of
fails because it cannot extrapolate and
miss coffee bean counts this as an a for
generalization we think gary marcus
would say told you so neural networks do
not extrapolate okay then let's forget
about the coefficient variance and let's
look at the experiments where the
eigenvalues of the matrices have
different distributions well again if
the distribution changes from train to
test sets the results are again bad if
not catastrophic for some configurations
then what to do in order to generalize
spoiler carefully adjust the training
data what helps generalization is when
hold on to your chair the training set
is enlarged such that its distribution
captures more of the different types of
matrices this goes exactly towards the
point we made in our video about
foundation models that of course out of
distribution generalization happens when
we increase the training distribution so
much that the whole world was in it yes
this paper is not enough to draw this
conclusion but hints into this direction
so no we do not agree with the points
made by the authors here that actual
generalization happens it might be very
well that we mean something different
with generalization we think
but the point of the authors maybe is
that by varying the training set one can
increase performance on out of domain
tasks but miss coffee bean is allergic
to these big words and argues that this
is not the point of generalization
because generalization happens when the
model got it and found the algorithm
behind eigenvalue decomposition and can
apply it successfully to really unseen
distributions but yes it's too much to
expect sure and if we are already at the
generalization buzzword let's go to the
next buzzword
view shot the argument of the authors
here is that the models trained on small
matrices like 5 times 5 do not
generalize to larger matrices then the
model trained on 40 million examples can
be further trained to also solve bigger
matrices with about 25 million more
examples
okay sounds fair but what does not sound
fair is that this is put into relation
with the word few shot is 25 million
examples few shot now is it just miss
coffee bean for whom few shot is at most
20 or 300 examples since when is few
shot in the order of millions and more
than half the amount of training data
during initial training what do you
think what is few infuse shot and is
this successful out of domain
generalization as presented in the paper
or just visual thinking but not quite or
let's make generalization less of a
binary variable so we want to ask you
how much percent generalization is there
let us know what you think in the
comments okay miss coffee bean the
terminology police coffee bean will go
now do not take her too seriously on her
rants about buzzwords i'm writing papers
myself and i must admit that buzzwords
help
if these are loosely defined evolving
and changing over used words why not use
them to one's own advantage hey miss
coffee bean you're still here yes you
are because you have something to tell
look we have been doing this egg coffee
break quiz in our community tab for
quite a while now we have posted over
200 questions there already and yes we
are kind of running out of ideas so if
you dear audience member want to
contribute over there and you have an
idea for a question
just email us and we will post it and we
will also credit you
okay bye
[Music]
[Music]
you